[Música]
has imaginado alguna vez un mundo ideal
uno sin guerra pobreza o delitos si es
así no eres el único Platón imaginó una
República iluminada gobernada por Reyes
filósofos muchas religiones prometieron
felicidad en la vida futura Y a lo largo
de la historia varios grupos han tratado
de construir el paraíso terrenal el
libro de Tomás moro utopía de 15 16 dio
nombre a este concepto que en griego
significa ningún lugar Aunque el nombre
sugiere la imposibilidad con el progreso
moderno se despertó la esperanza de que
estos sueños finalmente se hagan
realidad Pero en cambio se convirtieron
repetidamente en pesadillas bélicas en
hambre y opresión
y como los artistas empezaron a
cuestionar el pensamiento utópico nació
el género de la distopía el lugar no
bueno Jonathan Swift escribió una de las
primas obras distópicas los viajes de
glier en su viaje goulier encuentra
sociedades ficticias algunas parecen
impresionantes pero resultan ser muy
imperfectas en la isla voladora la
científicos y trabajadores sociales
trazan esquemas extravagantes e inútiles
mientras que descuidan las necesidades
reales de la gente de la tierra y los
hinan que viven en perfecta armonía
lógica no toleran las imperfecciones de
los seres humanos
reales con su novela Swift sentó las
bases de la distopía al imaginar un
mundo donde ciertas tendencias en la
sociedad contemporánea se llevan
demasiado lejos y exponen así sus
carencias Y esto quedó demostrado
durante los siglos
siguientes la tecnología que prometía
liberar a los trabajadores acabó por
marginalizar losos y esclavizarlos en
fábricas mientras que los magnates Se
volvieron más ricos que los reyes muchos
ya cuestionaban el efecto de Tales
condiciones a finales del siglo X La
máquina del tiempo de hg Wells imaginó
la clase alta y la trabajadora
evolucionando como especie separadas y
el talón de hierro de Jack London
retrató a una oligarquía tiránica que
gobierna sobre las masas
empobrecidas el siglo XX trajo cambios
emocionantes y
aterradores los avances médicos
posibilitaron trascender los límites
biológicos y los medios permitieron la
comunicación instantánea entre los
líderes hacia el
público en un mundo feliz de aldus
huxley los ciudadanos están
genéticamente modificados y
condicionados para cumplir sus funciones
sociales mientras que la propaganda y
las drogas mantienen a la sociedad feliz
algún elemento humano crucial se pierde
pero las distopías más famosas no eran
en absoluto
imaginarias mientras Europa estaba en
guerra nuevos movimientos políticos
llegaban al poder algunos prometían
borrar las diferencias y otros trataban
de reunir a la gente alrededor de un
legado
mítico los resultados fueron distopias
del mundo real donde la vida ocurría
bajo la atenta vigilancia Estatal y a
cualquiera que no perteneciera le
esperaba una despiadada
muerte muchos escritores de la época
fueron testigos de estos horrores y los
vivieron en su novela nosotros el
escritor soviético yevgeni stin
describió un futuro donde el libre
albedrío y la individualidad eran
radicados prohibido en la ex Unión
soviética El libro inspiró a autores
como George orwell que lucharon contra
el fascismo y el
comunismo rebelión en la granja se
burlaba abiertamente del régimen
soviético mientras que su clásico
1984 fue una crítica más amplia del
totalitarismo los medios de comunicación
y el lenguaje y en no puede suceder aquí
Sinclair Lewis previó como la democracia
dio lugar al fascismo luego de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial los escritores se
preguntaban qué significaban para el
futuro de la humanidad las nuevas
tecnologías como la energía atómica la
Inteligencia artificial y los viajes
espaciales contraria a la creencia
Popular en un progreso brillante la
ficción científica distópica se expandió
a las películas los cómics y los
juegos así los robots Se volvieron
contra sus creadores mientras que la
televisión difundió películas fatalistas
los obreros trabajaban en colonias
espaciales dejando atrás una tierra con
recursos agotados y ciudades
superpobladas plagadas de delitos pero
la política nunca estaba lejos doctor
insólito y Los vigilantes narran La
amenaza de una guerra nuclear mientras
que ve de venganza y el cuento de la
criada lo fácil que desaparecerían
nuestros derechos en una
crisis la ficción distópica de hoy
continúa reflejando la preocupación por
la desigualdad el cambio climático El
poder del gobierno y las
epidemias Entonces por qué con ese
pesimismo Porque en esencia las
distopias son cuentos que advierten no
sobre algún gobierno o tecnología en
particular sino que la humanidad puede
moldearse con base en un
ideal piensa en el Mundo perfecto que
imaginaste también te imaginaste lo que
haría falta para que se vuelva realidad
Cómo harías que la gente
cooperara y cómo te asegurarías de que
durara ahora mira otra vez aún parece
perfecto ese
mundo suscríbete a este canal y no
pierdas nunca la oportunidad de aprender
algo
[Música]
nuevo